[Music]  you guys have really been through the  reality-tv  relationship thing and been again the  success story what advice you have for  like Rachel and Brian to shrug off the  haters yeah it's gonna affect you and  just enjoy it because you know people  like see you out and they just love you  they love love they love this show I  think just just embracing that love and  taking an enamine like this is  incredible who's your pick for bachelor  we always have thoughts well well I  think Wells would be the great dark  horse candidate it would be hilarious  are you not on the team Peter team bean  trains know Dean's too young Pierre was  on a mission to be the bachelor which if  he makes it good for him he was really  smart out in the universe but not guy  was he said all of the right bachelor  things to say and kudos to him for  getting honest things but you know I  think Wells would be a great choice